[Music]
president trump has directed 12 billion
into a plan to develop a coronavirus
vaccine in record time
it's called operation warp speed the
goal
to have 300 million doses of a safe
effective vaccine
by january of 2021 enough to inoculate
first responders
and the highest risk groups in the
country it's risky
it's expensive but we'll be saving
massive amounts of time we'll be saving
years but the pressure to get it out
is forcing pharma companies to rush
through steps
that's dangerous because it could result
in a product that causes side effects
or just doesn't work and the lack of
transparency on how this money is being
spent
and how decisions are being made worries
some experts
i think operation worth speed is a black
box operation warp speed is trying to
move
as quickly as they can to develop a
vaccine and there's always a balance
there between how much you inform the
public along the way
and actually move forward with a program
congress is also concerned
and recently lost an investigation into
operation warp speed
more details about the program have
started to emerge but only
after key decisions were made now that
we have completed our
major agreements we can talk we are
going to talk
non-stop about everything and nearly
everything about this effort is
unprecedented
creating a new vaccine has always been a
long complicated and expensive process
that can sometimes take up to a decade
trump indicated that the formula could
be finalized as early as october
which would mean a total turnaround time
of six months
it's just uh doesn't show the respect
that should be shown
to to nature which gives it secrets up
slowly and grudgingly and often with a
human price
a development for a vaccine or any drug
that the fda approves
typically unfolds in three phases in
phase one trials
researchers must prove that a vaccine
formula is safe
and has a low risk of side effects in a
small group of about 10 to 30 people
in phase 2 that formula is given to a
larger group
from 50 to 300. the test group for the
third and final phase for any new
vaccine
typically includes 10 000 people in july
two operation warp speed companies
moderna and pfizer bioentech
entered phase 3 trials with 30 000
volunteers
it's an extraordinarily large size group
since the goal is to make this vaccine
available to all americans
phase 3 is crucial because it shows how
a vaccine will affect the widest
cross-section of the population
as long as there's this commitment not
to rush the phase three clinical trials
i think
everything should be fine officially
operation warp speed
isn't skipping steps but shortening
their length while funding multiple
simultaneous trials
and the mystery of operation warp speed
shrouds how it's funded
around 12 billion dollars have already
been committed to six vaccine candidates
including household pharma brands like
johnson johnson
pfizer and astrazeneca insider recently
learned that government scientists
winnered a list of nearly 100 vaccines
to just 10 but the white house has not
released a complete list of companies
that have received funding
or exactly how they're being selected
moderna a lesser-known company before it
entered the vaccine race
has received two rounds of investment
about two and a half billion dollars in
total
the startup is the first warp speed
finalist to reach phase 3 trials
but their technology platform has never
successfully brought a drug to market
in case you missed that the company
leading the vaccine race
has never made an fda approved drug
that's not uncommon for a new biotech
company
and the federal government supported
modernist platform even before the
pandemic
but the company does have another
potential advantage
its connection to the head of operation
warp speed monsev slowly
monster slowly came over after serving
on the board of moderna to run this
operation as a contractor this has led
some people to have skepticism around
his ties to the industry and the
potential for him to have conflicts of
interest
slowly a former pharma executive and
venture capitalist
stepped down from the board of moderna
which has seen stock prices triple since
january
it's been extremely painful for me that
anybody would
even think that i took this job to
enrich
myself or my former colleagues
and slowly has another close
relationship with another warp speed
company
his former employer glaxosmithkline or
gsk
in july gsk received a 2.1 billion
dollar grant
the largest single investment under the
program to date
as of may slowly owned over 10 million
dollars in shares of the company's stock
even with all this money and effort
there's a chance a vaccine will never
happen other types of coronavirus such
as mers and sars
have been known for decades no vaccine
has ever been approved for use in the
u.s against these strains
and researchers are still trying to
figure out how people develop covet 19
immunity
and how long it lasts once we will know
i think the room for speculation will
stop
and room for assessment and
understanding will
will start but even if scientists can
unlock those secrets
the plan for how the government will
deliver a vaccine to hundreds of
millions of americans
remains unclear there are very few
pharmaceutical companies
that have the manufacturing capabilities
and expertise
to ramp up the process so quickly and at
these massive scales
and for operation warp speed there's
still one major known
unknown will people take it
[Music]
the last time the federal government
funded a mass immunization campaign for
a new virus
it did not go according to plan in
february 1976
after a u.s soldier died from a new
strain of swine flu the government
orchestrated a 137 million dollar public
immunization campaign
but the pandemic never came and research
showed that the swine flu vaccine
may have made some people sick with a
rare autoimmune disorder
it's an incident that anti-vaxxers point
to as proof that all vaccines are unsafe
and that the government can't be trusted
to develop them
it's an opinion that's amplified by
social media
recent surveys indicate that just half
of americans plan to get a coronavirus
vaccine
some speculate that anti-vaccine
disinformation
may convince enough people that it could
derail efforts around a coronavirus
vaccine
i think most people are vaccine skeptics
as they should be i think you should be
skeptical of anything you put in your
body
i think it's a small percentage of
people who are vaccine cynics some are
treating misinformation
as its own kind of infection it's over
double
the amount of information online than it
was in december in a pandemic you need
the right information and if you look
for information about vaccines
on social media sites or on websites the
misinformation finds you
search engines are likely to recommend
conspiracy theory videos about
5g or bill gates it's much harder to get
accurate
science-based information to go viral
just look at how quickly mass became a
polarizing issue
there is concern that the trump
administration could attempt to
similarly politicize the vaccine
setting up an october surprise
announcement just in time for the
presidential election
could you assure the american people
that politics and considerations around
the election will not
interfere with the silence we want to
make people better
we want to send them to the areas that
most need it and i think we're going to
have something very soon it's going good
science shouldn't be political the
um in the case of vaccines we should we
should
allow this process to proceed the way
that it's proceeded for the last 70
years which is to say phase one phase 2
phase 3 trials and then licensure
operation warp speed is a gamble with
incredibly high stakes
the reopening of the economy the 2020
election
and the promise of a return to a new
normal there's so much urgency on this
moment to have a vaccine where
if the science doesn't live up to the
political expectations around these
programs
it's it's hard to imagine what would
happen if these vaccines just don't work
you